[Music]
the previous video got us familiar to
the concept of indicators indicators are
the substances that are used to detect
the acidic or basic nature of solutions
we have seen how turmeric acts
efficiently as a natural indicator now
let's talk about another natural
indicator and that is China rose China
rose is a plant so how can that be used
as an indicator the fact is the flowers
of China rose possess a good ability of
detecting acids and bases so how do we
use China rose flower as an indicator
it's very simple all we have to do is
add hot water to the petals of China
rose in a beaker and let it rest for
some time this solution can be used as
an indicator when drops of this are
added to an acidic solution then the
color of the solution changes to magenta
red or a slightly different shade of red
for that matter
however when added to an alkaline
solution the color of the alkali changes
to green or yellowish green to be
precise the solutions change color in
very less time and that is how we use
China rose as an indicator however
sometimes it's not very convenient to
add the indicator to the solution in
such cases some different type of system
is required something more efficient so
in such cases litmus paper comes to our
rescue what our litmus papers well
before that tell me have you come across
the terms Lycans yes we have studied in
biology that the symbiotic relation of
algae and fungi gives us a unit called
lichens the major function of lichens in
an ecosystem is that they act as a
pollution indicator their growth is
hindered when there is excessive
pollution as a result chemical changes
in the body of lichens can give us
indications of the nature of substance
says that come in contact with them so a
substance extracted from a lichens body
called litmus is used as a natural
indicator for chemical purposes
especially in detecting the acidic and
basic nature of solutions the litmus
obtained from a lichens body is a
mixture of some dyes that are usually
absorbed on a filter paper this paper
made with litmus on it is used as an
indicator for detecting acids and bases
two colors of litmus papers are usually
available red litmus paper and blue
litmus paper the red litmus paper when
comes in contact with an acid displays
no color change but turns blue in
presence of a base in contrast to this
the blue litmus paper turns red on
contacting an acid while it remains
unchanged in a basic solution this is
how several compounds are used as
indicators that help us in detecting the
acidic and alkaline nature of solutions
let us now move ahead and find out what
happens when we mix an acid and a base
but we know this already we have seen
that an acid and a base when mixed gives
us salt and water let's study this
neutralization reactions in detail in
the next video
[Music]